[Music]
spee
spe
foree
spee
[Music]
for you like being in other people's
business trying very hard not to be but
you make it very challenging for
me you should the other things are not
your
concern okay it's bad for you H Lord
knows I'm allergic to bad
things you
know I believe that everything in
life is about timing now unfortunately
for you yours isn't very
good 3 weeks ago we wouldn't be having
this conversation but I'm here
now I'm really beginning to like this
place and the
people I'm starting to believe from the
bottom of my heart that this is where
I'm supposed to be so whatever it is
that you and your friends do please do
it somewhere
else
bab you warning me I'm preparing
you is that a
timx
no
a right there right
there that's the median
nerve that I'm
compressing on scale from 1 to 10 that's
a
two that's a three you don't want me to
go to four I go to four your on
yourself they don't want that I don't
want that they don't want
that
tell your compat that they can leave to
beat
it it's called pain
compliance your brain is telling you to
do one thing but your body is telling
you something
else now listen to me take the gun out
of your ways
put it on the
table
y
[Music]
fore
spee
it
Vincent don't cut so
incent
spee
[Music]
o
[Applause]
[Music]
this
spee
fore forign
[Music]
spe